I know a guy that's large and Korean yep
we're on the 134 and I see him going in
the car Poe and I know for damn sure he
was the only one in that car save it
[Music]
though oh we kind of talked about stuff
like this but you know it's always funny
and it's always a good reminder for all
of us who use things like Postmates or
door Dash God damn it dude what's wrong
with those things I got to stop using
that [__] you guys order a lot of food I
do [__] yeah I do my new my favorite
thing is Costco I get in bulk yeah I
actually enjoy cooking a little bit now
mhm it's fun but it does take a lot of
time H when you get good it's quick
quicker than waiting for food that's
true I to me I disagree because for me
it's like I feel like I'm pretty good at
cooking I can cook them if [__] I mean
cook some food for us next I will dude
but it's just like the cleanup and then
it's like I if I have an hour to eat but
what's the wife for she don't clean like
that dishwasher just thr we have
dishwasher oh so it's just like also you
can cook and then just know that you're
making four meals in one
sitting when I want Menino Farms I want
mesino Farms okay all right check this
video out $4 for a
sandwich for two thank you here we
go all right so it's very small but
we'll see it the door Dash
delivery take the picture
CL they didn't leave me
nothing he's spitting he's spitting on
it yeah he just spits on the back what
is he spitting for oh cuz of the tip no
tip apparently oh my God Dam wait does
it do you add the tip before or do you
put it in after you can do both you can
do both that's crazy oh so this uh door
Dash has removed this delivery driver
from their platform after his video
appears to show him spitting on the
customer's order can he just make
another account he has a funny accent he
does have a funny accent don't they all
Europeans not all of them exactly you
know what is kind of nuts though so that
guy probably also drives Uber right M
and when you get into his Uber you're
technically like letting him be in
control of your life yeah it's pretty
crazy it I think about that a lot for
Ubers yeah cuz I'm like are you a better
driver than me cuz I'm not good already
yeah
oh but I'll pay for the convenience yeah
no definit
that's what you're paying for cuz I
don't know what other options I got like
you got to call a cab to be to pick you
up just you call a cab company and say
hey can you pick me up at 5:30 a.m. what
do people do back in the day and they
you know the cab drivers aren't even as
good anymore back in the day like what
they like took pride in is knowing the
streets like the back of their hand
they're go oh drop me off of lanor him
whatever oh I know I get there or they
go I know a shortcut yeah nowadays
they're like can you please type into M
GP yes i'm like [__] you're doing the
same [__] Uber is the GPS is ruining
everyone's sense of direction I think
that's true overall it's ruined mine it
did ruin mine but I'm not mad at it I
like GPS though even if I know how to
get there because it tells me where's
traffic yeah that's nice that's a cool
feature cuz I sometimes be like I used
to be like man I know la like the back
of my hand and then I get on the fre and
I'm like
[__] gridlock man [__] but then when you
when you see before and you have your
destination you're like H I'm going to
avoid going on the highway today how
often do you guys do illegal [__] for
all oh I shouldn't say on camera oh
you're on a a
motorcycle so it's this will it depends
on where it depends on where and how
empty the are one time I had a friend
and there's gridlock so he went on the
shoulder and then he got immediately got
pulled over so in his brain the next day
he was like what are the chances of it
happening two times in a row and it h
and he was like [__] it in traffic pull
over his shoulder and got two times in a
row [__] I saw somebody do third times a
charm that's a for reason no I'm not
going to do me too I don't like those
Cutters yeah no you just look at them
like what the yeah you're lame
disgusting mother you know what I mean
like you're [__] lame splitting yeah
but I take up no space you know let me
just get out your guys' way for you guys
and then go home I actually ha is legal
in California I actually hate the uh
those shoulder guys more than Racers
nobody likes CU Racers I'm like o That's
dangerous but let me get out of the way
right and I'm like oh I remember what
that's like or maybe one's trying to
kill another guy or maybe they got to
really go pee right so like I don't know
what about carpool lane you guys go on
the carpool lane when it's just you
without any when when there's no people
on it what do you think of those people
that do that be honest just die just
[__] man yeah idiots right I think
fast track I you know I saw somebody I
saw there's times where I do it doing it
that we're all very close to and we
don't look at me like that now it wasn't
clean it wasn't clean he was he's a
large Korean man and we were driving we
were leaving Burbank coming home I know
a guy that's large and Korean yep we're
on the 134 and I see him going in the
car poane and I know for damn sure he
was the only one in that car save it D
and I save it D and I was disgusted I
was absolutely disgusting but I bet save
it no would be in deep ation switching
four lanes and he didn't know I'll tell
you this can I say something I think
you're wrong because I saw him we were
in the same lane together he threw on
his blinker to go in go into it blinking
into dude hiding in plain sight it's
like consciously being like I'm I'm
allowed to do this and as soon as we're
driving away I was like you think you
know somebody you think you think you
know somebody I guarantee you I I could
even put a deeply disappoint you I could
even put a bet that if you told him that
it was a carpool lane he'll be like no
it's
not yeah probably probably and you'll
look back and go oh my god I've been Dr
what have I done but I thought it was an
empty Lane did he get home way sooner
than I did yeah how's this there are
times where I'll do that but just to get
over somebody being so slow in the fast
lane just so I can get get around them
can't do it just do it I don't do it cuz
bikers pass that times like that which
is like maybe 5% of the time and then
the other percent I'm just doing
it it's
okay I've seen one where I was driving
next to this truck and then uh I'm like
dude the guy in the back seat is wearing
the [__] biggest on bro I've ever
seen and then when I get close and I
look over they just put this umbrella on
the headrest I was like fuart je I do
that [__] with my hat sometimes I bet
cops would probably that's why you wear
hats huh mhm [__] like D I got to start
wearing some hats as a person in the car
put hats on every headrest I haven't
been seeing people get pulled over these
days as much I have going straight
towards Irvine jere Road exit well
that's irine City takes care of itself
and follows rules the right way y this
my first time in irine too I was like
what the hell these guys are on it you
know they try to do a take over there
and they're like nope prob it shuts down
real fast they actually got everybody I
[__] love Irvine for that re I love
Irvine yeah it's just so clean so wide
so peaceful D everyone's white you like
Republican cities is what you're saying
huh I didn't know you were altri right
first keep on going put put the words in
my mouth go ahead this is about a a sad
customer who got spat on with their food
and your should have tipped dude they
should have TI [__] on me go ahead I was
talking [__] you insensitive [__] yeah B
that's what I thought save it though no
you
just
Republican
ban cart cartw cart laon BT Bert swan
that's probably the best one still this
is a 13-year-old kid who has a [__]
uh a ring camera he said he tipped $3
even though the guy
$1 you know what I'm that guy sometimes
that I go I don't tip unless I know
because sometimes they they you tip and
then they don't deliver it or some [__]
yeah or they get the order wrong it's
all [__] up you know what I mean so I
usually try to tip after but now I'm
like I'm just scared you just get it
back you make a report if they [__] up
and then you mess Mage them and they
give you back the money with a tip look
this dude obviously is a scumbag you
know but he's probably not like what
what other job is he going to have he
could he he like like customer service
stuff you spit on maybe he should be in
customer service I think you should I
think it teaches him character CU now
all the go-to jobs like uber postm what
they're all customer service maybe
should be is there like a racket going
on with that by the way do you ever see
it when you like order food right and
it's like this person's pulling up in
this car but then a different car shows
up yeah [__] or different people yeah or
different people I've done that like the
photos of a guy and like a girl shows up
or vice versa yeah what is that it's not
and you you know it's not like El not
like the boyfriend or the girl and
they're chilling it's like just a
different person you're like is there
some underground ring going on maybe
that's crazy or maybe they're just you
know different no I've done it because I
I registered my truck to do Uber Eats
before but then I tried it for 2 days
and I was like this is [__] horrible
yeah ass parking but my mom gave me uh
my brother's car cuz he went to the
military so I just been using that so
even my car account say truck but I just
use a silver CA and people have a hard
time finding me yeah so Uber Eats is not
that good because you have to pay a lot
of stuff out of pocket no it's just uh
gas sometimes and you don't pay anything
out of pocket so they cover your gas oh
except gas yeah yeah
sorry they vet you do they are they like
give us your work res or is anybody can
just how did you become an Uber Eats
driver uh when the strike happened and I
was just playing games for one straight
week and I was like dude I'm a dummy I
got to actually work but I don't want to
work so I'm just going to Uber that's
how I got into
it and then how did you sign up did they
meet did you have to meet a recruiter or
anything no background check picture of
your ID that's it boom good to go start
they don't check your car make sure you
have a decent car only when you're doing
uh Uber Uber you have to take it to a
shop and you have they have to fill up
so just like a uber shop wow no they
they partner it up with a bunch of gas
uh what do you call it like yeah smart
so [__]
[Music]
smart
f